today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink ascom slash david pakman
I put the link right below this video
for years are really even for decades
the gun people as they're sometimes
known the pro-gun activists the gun
fetishists the National Rifle
Association other groups they've been
warning us they've been telling us we
absolutely need more guns we need more
guns in more places we need guns
everywhere because the government could
become tyrannical it's possible that
someone might try to turn the United
States into a police state it could be a
president who is a totalitarian
nightmare who might do something like
deploying the military across the
country and those exact same people have
been silent as Donald Trump has said he
doesn't care what governors say he'll
send in the military if he wants to to
suppress protests that are protected by
the First Amendment and in fact as we
saw the National Guard and very
militarized police units and riot squads
deployed to protests around the country
which have been overwhelmingly peaceful
the NRA and the gun people have said
nothing we saw a riot squad take down
Martin Gugino an unarmed 75 year old man
knocked over by police hitting his head
bleeding from his ear spending nearly a
week in the hospital and the president
got involved to attack the protester
rather than the police who did this this
is exactly what the NRA and others have
been warning us about and as matt Cohen
writes for Mother Jones all of those
people all of those groups have been
absolutely silent Wayne LaPierre from
the NRA wrote 25 years ago that it's
possible that quote jackbooted
government thugs
would get more power to take away our
constitutional rights destroy our
property even injure us if you can
imagine that if assault weapons were
banned
which was the discussion in 1995 when
wayne lapierre wrote that we saw during
the barack obama presidency the nra
other gun groups activists fear
mongering
that barack obama the scary half black
possibly Muslim foreign guy was going to
come and take everybody's guns he was
going to confiscate all the guns and it
was a true liberal bogeyman and in
reality Barack Obama presided over one
of the largest expansions in gun
ownership a boon for gun sales that we
have seen in American history because of
that fear mongering and now the NRA is
silent the NRA is silent that maybe
George Floyd should have had a weapon to
defend himself as they sometimes like to
say about people in various sticky
situations as maybe the term is the NRA
completely silent about the repression
of protests and police brutality and
support and encouragement of that
brutality from the President and for
many of his Republican colleagues and
yet when state governments were saying
wear a mask
two months ago that was supposedly
tyrannical repression by the government
which had the gun people out in force at
state capitals and on city streets the
reality of course is that the NRA
and these other groups believe the
Second Amendment is fundamentally a
defense against liberals that's really
what you need guns for to defend
yourself against liberals and fake
liberal bogeyman the NRA doesn't really
care about gun rights or tyranny they
care about selling guns and funneling
money to Republicans and it would be
very problematic for the NRA to say at
this point listen don't we need people
to take up guns to protect ourselves
from the militarized tyrannical police
and riot gear it would be terrible for
optics if they said that it would put
them at odds with the establishment it
would be seen as encouraging violence
and when they talk about defending the
gun rights of law-abiding citizens the
idea in their heads is of a white
conservative man now of course look
listen I've been around enough
no they include carefully selected safe
instances of defending the gun rights of
soccer moms with a handgun in their
purse and you know picking out some
black folks who hold up as look here
here's some examples but the silence
that we're seeing in light of the recent
protests and repression by police
surprises nobody who's been paying
attention
remember falando castile falando castile
was a black man who legally owned a gun
did exactly as instructed by police was
calm complied and he was killed without
real consequences for the officers
involved where was the nra and after the
fact the nra came up with this sort of
post hoc rationalization from their
spokeswoman dana loesch i don't know if
dana loesch is still a spokeswoman she
was at the time and she said well the
reason we're not coming to the defense
of falando cast the illegal gun owner
who did exactly what police asked and
was still killed happened to be black is
he not only had a firearm he was in
possession of a controlled substance at
the same time he had drugs on him and
that's illegal and that's how the nra
was able to say who we don't have to go
out there and defend volando castile
because he had drugs on him ah right
that must have been what it was and
before i forget the nra also exists i
alluded to this before to funnel dark
money to republicans through political
advertising we saw that in 2016 with the
Trump campaign they the NRA helped Trump
get elected by funneling shadowy money
directly into pro Trump campaign online
advertising campaigns investigations
into that were started they were
attempted they didn't go very far I
think you won't be shocked to hear so
again back when it was protests because
the government wants us to stay home and
wear masks when we're out they brought
their guns out and I was thinking that
this is the government tyranny public
health guidelines like mask wearing and
holding off on haircuts for the time
being the
is the government tyranny and then now
as we see heavily militarized police
forces come out in response to protests
about government right I mean when we
talk about police using force and
killing people that is government
overusing force the government might
become tyrannical people are missing
they're gone and in fact they're
criticizing the protesters so never ever
ever ever again if you ever fell for it
to begin with
should you fall for any of these talking
points we need guns because the
government might become tyrannical we
support we we always come out in support
of people who have been victimized by
actors elements of government and lawn
for it's it's that's not what it's ever
been about it's about selling guns it's
about defending primarily their main
constituents which are conservative
white men with exceptions of course and
as a funnel conduit for getting money to
Republican politicians that's what they
exist for and they're proving at every
single day yesterday we did an entire
story about the 75 year old protestor
Martin Gugino
who was attacked by Buffalo Police
shoved onto the ground hit the back of
his head caused bleeding from his ear
now I'm not going to give you that full
story again because we just did it
yesterday but the big shock since
yesterday is that Donald Trump's press
secretary Kaley McKenna knee has doubled
and tripled down on Donald Trump's
attacks of the protester not of the
police what we go back a little bit
yesterday Donald Trump tweeted about
this altercation quote Buffalo
protesters shoved by police could be an
Tifa provocateur 75 year old Martin
Gugino was pushed away after appearing
to scan police communications in order
to black out the equipment Oh a n I
watched he fell harder than was pushed
was aiming scanner could be a setup so
this was a where did Trump get this as
he says this is a story from Oh a n
which is a wacky it's e
crazier than FoxNews they did a segment
promoting these baseless conspiracies
Trump bought it hook line and sinker it
was sick so yesterday
Trump's press secretary Kaley mcenany is
asked about this on Fox & Friends and
she doubles down with a complete trash
response let's take a look at it
yesterday the president koe was a
tweeted out that this Buffalo protester
the 75 year old who was shoved to the
ground by a police officer might have
been part of Antipa and a provocateur in
order to get that type of reaction just
to paraphrase could you expand on that
does the president think that this this
guy is part of an Tifa so the president
was raising questions based on a report
that he saw are there questions that
need to be asked in every case we can't
jump on one side okay so I want to
interrupt us for a moment
Trump was asking questions based on the
report he saw the report he saw was a
completely speculative irresponsible
segment from a channel called Oh a n
which Trump increasingly loves because
they kowtow to him a hundred percent of
the time rather than 98 percent of the
time which is what Fox News does it's a
segment which asserted no facts
whatsoever it was mere speculation that
she says is the basis for Trump's tweet
let's continue every case we can't jump
on one side without looking at all the
facts at play this individual had some
very questionable tweets and
profanity-laden tweets okay I have to
stop again Kaley mckennon he says 75
year old Martin Gugino
who was attacked by police tweeted
questionable things that had swears
let's just apply basic critical thinking
did the officers interacting with googy
know know about his tweets when they
knocked him down causing him to bleed
out of his ear and putting him in the
hospital for nearly a week of course
they didn't they didn't know who he was
and most importantly most importantly
tweeting swear words doesn't mean that
it's warranted for police to knock you
over and put you in the hospital right I
thought this was America this is
disgusting the president's press
secretary asserting as a defense of
Trump attacking the protester that the
protester once tweeted questionable
things with swear words if you can
imagine anything more milquetoast this
is a tragedy let's continue some
profanity-laden tweets about police
officers of course no one condones any
sort of violence we need the appropriate
amount of force used in any interaction
but there are a lot of questions in that
case in fact you had 56 police officers
who resigned in protest of how their
fellow officers were treated so there's
the grand finale we're all disgusted
that so many officers resigned in
defense of the cops who did this but
Caylee is citing the resignations as
proof that the officers were in the
right the reality is that Buffalo PD has
a very long history of this type of get
in line no matter what they've done sort
of nonsense and that's exactly what
we're seeing here it's horrifying that
Trump even stepped into this by tweeting
things that were antagonistic of the
protester and now his press secretary is
doubling down then she was asked about
it again during her press briefing so
the clip I showed you is from Fox in the
morning yesterday then she did a press
briefing starting about 4550 minutes
late and she tripled down let's take a
look at that the president was asking
questions about an interaction and a
video clip he saw and the president has
the right to ask those questions regret
tweeting out this protester was
assaulted the President does not regret
standing up for law enforcement men and
women across this country
so here Kaley tries to make it about
Trump standing up for law enforcement
this actually weakens law enforcement
this is really an important it this is
not a trivial matter here when law
enforcement does something so obviously
wrong and the president defends it it
reduces trust in law enforcement which
worsens the situation on the ground
if Trump actually criticized the
officers here it would increase trust
that when law enforcement so obviously
misbehaves there will be agreement that
they misbehaved we all lose when Donald
Trump does this and just one more piece
of this clip about so-called facts
gun coming up rather husband to have
fast before he tweets anything out he's
the President of the United States the
President did have fax before he tweeted
out that undergirded his quest was
conspiracy theory is conspiracy no not
at all I won't acknowledge that because
look you had let's contrast this to the
George Floyd situation which that
horrific video that we all saw every
single police officer that I saw across
the country came out and said this is an
inexcusable action and I condemn this
police officer in this case there were
57 police officers who said I resign in
protest so again with the police
officers who resigned who actually
should be ashamed of themselves but more
importantly Kayleigh McKenna knee says
Trump did have facts when he tweeted and
repeated those attacks against 75 year
old Martin googy no he did not all Trump
had when he tweeted about this attacking
Martin Gugino were the baseless
conspiratorial assertions of an OE n
segment this is sick and remember that
there is a I don't want to call it a
strategy but there is a political impact
to this which is that sewing division is
good for Trump if he can get people
doubting who's good and bad even in such
an obvious interaction as the one that
Martin Gugino had with police if people
can be arguing about well you know whose
side are we on that prevents people from
uniting about anything and that is
exactly what Trump needs Trump needs a
divided country so that they don't unite
and realize it's obviously time for a
change it's obviously time for a change
in November let's not fall for it quick
reminder chess tournament David Pakman
show chess tournament Tuesday June 16 at
8:00 p.m. Eastern I hope you will join I
hope you will play we did this once
before had 500 participants let's go for
a thousand we will be doing the
tournament on the website Lee chess org
li chess org this is all free you're
invited it's free to everybody I'll be
streaming the tournament and anybody who
wants to play can play all skill levels
welcome Tuesday 8 p.m. June 16th
remember to get the David Pakman show
daily podcast
whatever podcasting app you prefer
iTunes stitcher Google play's Spotify
all of those are available and lastly
let me know what you make of this entire
Martin budino thing I'm on twitter at
the Pakman and I look forward to hearing
from him the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinka
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash david pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are cheryl perry and tina beck
cheryl and tina thank you for your
support i so appreciate it i also want
to say thanks to today's longtime
sustaining member of the day that's
Katherine Brophy Katherine you've been a
member
almost five years members of course get
all of the great perks aside from the
mood boost of knowing you're supporting
alternatives to corporate media you get
the daily commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show and a bunch of
other great stuff sign up in under a
minute at join pakman.com and always
feel free to take advantage of the 66%
discount code that code is 2020 now all
one word - zero to zero n o w okay some
really interesting post popped up this
morning on the david pakman show reddit
i encourage you to participate at david
pakman.com slash reddit we are just 90
or so subscribers short on the reddit of
20,000 it's free subscribe at david
pakman.com slash reddit user Rickard 58
or Rick hard posted 100 reasons not to
vote for Donald Trump in November and in
reading this the the point and they're
all perfectly good reasons including
Trump's continued lies I mean just to
pick one thing he said he would release
his tax returns he still hadn't right I
mean just like you could pick any one of
these things that the tariff with China
disaster failed coronavirus responds on
and on and on there are people who are
arguing that Democrats want things to be
worse for the next five months
economically and in terms of the virus
to justify removing Donald Trump and to
every single one of them I continue to
say Trump could stop doing bad things
today and not do another quote bad thing
for the next five months he would still
deserve to be removed in other words as
a person who cares about others I want
the economy to recover as quickly as
possible and I don't want a single
additional person to die of Corona
and even if that happened today I would
still vote to remove Donald Trump
because of what he's already done and I
think that's an important thing to keep
in mind when these right-wingers talk
about you're trying to make coronavirus
worse to hurt Trump know the the case
for removing Trump has been written
already and again as I said if he solves
every geopolitical conflict and cures
all disease in the next five months come
back to me and we can talk about it but
just look at what he's done for the last
three and a half years that has that
that is a ticket to removal from the
White House if I've ever seen one also
from the David Pakman show subreddit
karaoke 24 asks if Mitt Romney was to
support and endorse Joe Biden do you
think there's a chance Biden could win
Utah or is Utah too deep read I tweeted
something similar the other day here's
my thought I think that if Mitt Romney
were to endorse Biden it would force
Trump to have to fight for Utah I don't
think Trump will ultimately lose Utah
Utah is very very conservative one of
the most conservative states in the
country however even in polling now it's
closer than it usually is and certainly
if Romney were to endorse Biden Trump
would have to spend money in Utah and
that would be a victory because every
dollar Trump has to spend to hold Utah
is a dollar he can't spend in Wisconsin
or Ohio or Pennsylvania or other states
that are more likely to make a
difference so I hope Romney does endorse
Joe Biden I already talked earlier this
week about how some on the Left are kind
of missing the mark in terms of
interpreting some of these Republicans
who are saying I can't I can't go I
can't vote for Trump I just can't do it
so I would love to see it I don't think
it gives you talk to Joe Biden but I
think it does give Trump a problem where
he has to spend money in Utah a lot of
posts I'm picking just one here but a
lot of posts thrilled about my thirty
five minute interview slash therapy
session on Tuesday evening with streamer
Steven Kenneth destiny bunnell the
second now I know some of you guys may
not know who he is
he's a figure in the Twitter
Gaming community and also there's a lot
of political debates and here's just one
of the posts about this David and
destiny should make a podcast that was
some of the best funny content I've seen
in a while
we should honestly have a David and
destiny podcast they're both pretty
funny and know a lot about the issues I
think there is a lot of demand for a
podcast on both fan bases many requests
for this you know for now it probably is
going to have to remain a sort of check
in every once in a while because I'm
pretty busy with everything I've got
going on but I really do appreciate that
people seem to to like that if you
missed it on the live stream we put the
full 35 minute in your interview with
Stephen Kenneth on the YouTube channel
and you can find it at youtube.com slash
the david pakman show and find all of
these discussions that you can
participate in at david pakman.com slash
reddit or search for the David Pakman
show
in the reddit app I'm actually surprised
that this next story continued to blow
up the way that it has Donald Trump is
now demanding that a pollster apologised
to him and cease and desist because a
poll said that he's losing to Joe Biden
and he doesn't believe that he's losing
to Joe Biden I guess so
this Monday this poll was published from
CNN remember that the CNN poll cNN
polling first of all is not the same as
CNN much the same way that Fox News Paul
polling is not the same as Fox News
broadcast the CNN SSRS poll said that
Joe Biden is ahead of Donald Trump
nationally by 14 points this is a huge
margin 55 to 41 we don't know if this
margin will hold this is just one poll
Trump was furious so first Trump started
tweeting that the poll is fake on
Tuesday Donald Trump hired some other
pollster to write a letter saying how
bad the CNN poll is including by lying
about the CNN poll so for example the
pollster that Trump hired said that this
was a poll of all adults rather than
people who are going to vote if you look
at the methodology of the poll you see
very clearly it is a poll of registered
voters now you can make the case that a
poll
of likely voters would be more accurate
but the poll is a poll of registered
voters this McLaughlin guy falsely
claimed it's a poll of all adults so the
debunk letter was riddled with lies then
Donald Trump started with the legal
threats triggered Trump demanding that
the poll be retracted and that CNN
apologized to him Trump says the poll
has to be retracted because he feels
it's not fair or accurate or well done
and that it seeks to suppress the vote
for Donald Trump now I look back let me
get to that let me get to the
suppression a little bit later the
letter that was written to CNN accuses
the network of trying to mislead voters
through a biased questionnaire and
skewed sampling claiming they released a
quote phony poll to cause voter
suppression Trump's cease and desist
letter which threatens legal action is
something I am not aware of ever
happening in this country the President
of the United States threatening legal
action over poll results that he doesn't
doesn't like or disagrees with is
completely outrageous this is the type
of thing you might imagine happens in
you know North Korea Venezuela China
Russia places like that you don't
imagine that in the u.s. Presidents
threaten pollsters over scientific polls
now it's important for you to know that
this poll is not that much of an outlier
in terms of Trump versus Biden so for
sure a 14-point lead for Biden is the
biggest that we've seen in any poll so
far but if you look at other recent
polls Joe Biden is ahead of Trump by 10
in a few polls by 11 in one poll so 14
is high but it's not like it's
completely crazy where every other poll
says it's a tie or Trump is winning and
CNN drops a poll that says Biden plus 14
when you look at May and June
Biden's winning every poll and it's a
matter of by how much the point is
demanding a retraction and an apology is
bizarre it shows number one again
Trump's a trigger able snowflake he is
he is so thin-skinned number two Trump
is insecure
about what's going on with polling
let me dig into that a little bit and
this is what I was going to get to
earlier Trump claims that a poll showing
Biden is winning will suppress or is
trying to suppress Trump voters from
turning out that only would be true if
your voters don't really like you that
much because in general if I find out
that the candidate I support is down if
anything that makes me more likely to go
out and vote in other words here in
Massachusetts I'm voting no matter what
in Massachusetts Biden is likely to win
if the polling says Biden is up thirty
in Massachusetts I'm going to vote
because I vote no matter what but I
might be less urgently voting then if a
poll came out and said Massachusetts in
play Trump only down two in
Massachusetts then I'm I mean I'm voting
either way but I'm even more definitely
going to get out and vote if that makes
sense so Trump's analysis that saying
Biden is winning is a way to try to
suppress Trump supporters from voting
they must be very unenthusiastic
supporters if they would be moved not to
vote because their guy is losing in a
lot of parts of the country with a lot
of types of people if you see your
candidate is down or that it's close you
are damn sure going to get out to vote
so that that's that now in terms of
CNN's response they said they stand by
the poll as expected that they did the
poll it's a they're a good pollster
that's it imagine ESPN being told hey
you've got a report a different final
score right imagine that the Boston
Celtics defeat the Washington what are
they called down to the Washington can I
forget what that is what are the name of
the Washington it used to be the bullet
the Wizards I'm sorry
imagine the Celtics defeat the Wizards
by 10 and Wizards management calls ESPN
and says could you report a different
score please because we just don't
really agree that that's the score how
does a Trump voter see this and see
Trump as the alpha male that he claims
to be
he doesn't like a poll so he cries and
says everyone's being unfair to him and
sends a legal threat to cowardly move go
win an election if you're sure that the
poll is fake and then we'll have all the
proof we need assuming it's a fair
election which Donald Trump is trying to
ensure it will not be to be honest I
feel like the presidency of Trump is far
more fake than the CNN poll but
ultimately we will know in five months
four and a half months at this point
five months four months three weeks
whether these polls reflect a rising
tide against Donald Trump or whether
he's going to be able to pull it off
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on Instagram at David Pakman
show many exciting things are happening
there the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the David Pakman show depends
on your support and the easiest way is
through membership which includes the
world's famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
Bernie Sanders is increasingly in
trouble mostly with folks who describe
themselves as supporters of Bernie just
a few weeks or a couple of months ago
and part of this was Bernie Sanders
endorsing Joe Biden that enraged some
people on the left and Bernie Sanders
now said in a new interview in in very
definitive terms basically exactly what
I said on Monday about this entire
abolish the police defund the police
thing which was he's not for defunding
the police that some departments need
more money but that many changes in
reforms has to be have to be made and
this was a very wide-ranging interview
with The New Yorker I encourage you to
check out the entire thing but listen
call me a neoliberal right-wing nut but
I agree with Bernie Sanders which
increasingly has people furious with me
as well which is just a strange turn of
events let's look at what Bernie said
Bernie when asked about these defund the
police movements said quote do I think
we should not have police departments in
America no I don't there's no city in
the world that does not have police
departments okay so this is this is just
a hard no on actually getting rid of
police departments fair enough some
people are angry with this but some
folks believe this part is reasonable
Bernie goes on what you need are I
didn't call for more money for police
departments I called for police
departments that have well educated well
trained well paid professionals and too
often around the country right now you
have police officers who take the job at
very low payment don't have much
education don't have much training and I
want to change them so again Bernie
pointing out sometimes police are
underpaid sometimes police are under
trained sometimes the department doesn't
have enough officers to actually do
community policing rather than what I
call cheap policing so that's me
editorializing I'm now adding on to what
Bernie Sanders said Bernie goes on quote
I also called for the transformation of
police departments into understanding
that many police departments and cops
deal every day with issues of
mental illness deal with issues of
addiction and all kinds of issues which
should be dealt with by mental health
professionals or others and not just by
police officers so again
Bernie spot-on exactly as I said on
Monday
I added mental health training for
officers themselves to better deescalate
adding to police departments more mental
health workers straight-up
who can request support from police if
necessary Bernie goes on to say quote I
think we want to redefine what police
departments do give them the support
they need to make their jobs better to
find so I do believe that we need
well-trained well-educated and well-paid
professionals in police departments
anyone who thinks that we should abolish
all police departments in America I
don't agree
so this is very straightforward I like
that bernie is also pointing out that a
lot of times when we look at funding we
would mostly I believe all agree that
funding for military like elements for
police including certain weapons and
riot gear armed vehicles etc that is
funding that should be cut but cutting
salaries particularly when in many parts
of the country police are dramatically
underpaid including being so underpaid
relative to the cost of living that they
have to live far from the area they are
policing which is not good for the
community I made this point earlier this
week sometimes you actually may need to
increase the amount that is going to
salaries as an example while decreasing
the amount that is going to
militarization and equipment so there
have been two primary reactions to
Bernie Sanders saying this one reaction
is people are furious with Bernie
Sanders once again
Bernie sold out again just like he sold
out by endorsing Joe Biden and to them I
say what really happened here like in
other words did you so misjudge Bernie
all of these years you believed he was
the most honest politician the most
genuine politician the best guy that we
needed and then now in six weeks Bernie
says I'm endorsing Biden and we should
vote for him and defund the police is
not something that that you know you
need to have police and now you realize
that all along for the last year two
years five years however long you
Porter Burnie your assessment of him was
just wrong what does that say about your
judgment if that is your reaction now
the other response has been well you
know abolish the police defund the
police it's not literal it's a metaphor
for reform but that is where a lot of
the problem is coming from these
conversations of we've got to defund the
police and abolish dismantle police
departments well that you you do need
police though like who are you going to
call in the middle of the night if
someone burgles your house well no no I
mean I don't actually mean defund or
abolish the police what I mean is the
stuff David Pakman said on Monday well
then maybe we agree but the movement
needs to do better branding because
there are some people who do want to
abolish the police but either way the
right is seizing on it and we're getting
crushed right wing media has spent all
week just arguing about the left wants
to defund and abolish the police when
even a lot of the people saying it don't
actually want to do that so it does to
me seem like Bernie's position might
just be to status quo and not radical
enough for some of Bernie's most ardent
followers that that actually may be the
case even without straw Manning or
mischaracterizing Bernie's position or
without making a personal attack on
Bernie it's possible that Bernie's
position on this issue is just not
radical enough for some of the people
that supported Bernie in 2016 and in
2020 now I saw one other perspective
when researching this I saw some Bernie
supporters who said we don't really
believe Bernie means this so understand
what what the argument is there are some
Bernie supporters who believe that deep
down Bernie does want to abolish the
police but in this interview he's
pretending that he doesn't in order to
mainstream Joe Biden's view which is the
same and that it's sort of like a tactic
in other words Bernie wants to defund
the police but as a posturing move to
help Biden Bernie's lying and pretending
that he doesn't want to defund the
police if you believe that then you
believe that Bernie Sanders is
incredibly dishonest and I don't know
how you could otherwise support him like
if you believe Bernie is actually just
straight up lying in this way that then
you should question why you're even why
you're even still defending Bernie in
any way I don't know if I'm honest with
you guys and I would never be anything
less than honest with you I'm actually
concerned about how quickly some Bernie
supporters abandoned Bernie after he
endorsed by Dhin and said a few
pragmatic things and a lot of Bernie
supporters abandoned Bernie very quickly
attributed the most bad faith
interpretations to everything that
Bernie has said and done since
suspending his campaign and endorsing
Joe Biden like this was the guy for you
and you abandon him this quickly and say
he's either disingenuous or a shill for
Biden or whatever to me that makes me
question whether you were really that
strong of a Bernie supporter from the
get-go
or you were only supportive of him as
far as he was saying the things you
wanted to hear and it wasn't really
Bernie you supported it was Bernie as
long as he says what you want to hear
and then as soon as he doesn't Bernie's
no longer you know the genuine thinker
that you'd met many many said that he
was I don't know but it is definitely
concerning what we're seeing this next
story is a political story but it's also
sort of a math story you know I love a
good math story and this math story has
to do with the fact that a lot of people
don't understand percentage versus
percentage points now two people who do
understand the difference please accept
my sincere apology that I have to do
this right now
but the amount of confusion over this
over the last 24 hours has forced my
hand and I have to do this so here's the
headline Donald Trump's approval rating
is down 10 points or you could also say
10 percentage points in the last month
so early in the corona virus pandemic
Donald Trump's approval actually went up
all the way up to 49% in the gallup
tracking poll it is now down to 39% so
Trump's approval went from 49% to 39
percent that's a decline of 10 points
the problem here is that some people
don't understand the difference between
percent and percentage points others
understand the concept but are using the
wrong term and just confusing other
people so
let's just work through a very quick
example if someone has 50% approval and
their approval goes down by 10% strictly
speaking that would mean 50% 10 percent
of 50 is 5 that means if you have 50
percent approval and approval goes down
10% you go from 50 to 45 okay 10 percent
of 50 is 5 so far I think we're clear if
you have an approval of 50 percent and
it drops 10 points also said 10
percentage points
that's a decline of 10 actual points
meaning you went from 50 to 40 you lost
10 points 50 minus 10 is 40 the
confusion comes when we're talking about
percent changes to things already
measured in percent okay so in this case
our real-world numbers our Trump's
approval spiked to 49 and then drop to
39 in a one-month period that's a
10-point decline but it is about a 20%
decline to his approval right if you
lose 10 out of 49 that's about 20% and
if you're now thoroughly confused forget
everything I've said the news part of
this story is that Trump's approval went
from 49 to 39 that's a very rapid
decline in fact I think it's the largest
one-month decline that trump has seen at
any time during his presidency now
there's good news and there's bad news
the good news is that clearly Donald
Trump's approval is not immune from his
actions in other words the failed
coronavirus response the totalitarian
instincts that came to light after the
George Floyd killing and the protests
that started this has hurt Donald Trump
that's good he's not immune the bad news
is that somehow 4 out of 10 Americans
still think he's doing a good job so
this may be a good time to remind you
that when it comes to presidential
approval when you think about how
divided the country is presidential
approval adds up to a hundred but
there's not really a hundred points of
approval in play there's some portion of
people who for ideological reasons will
never approve of the job that the
president
I don't know if that's like you know 10%
15% 20 I'm not really sure on the other
side you've got people who will never
abandon Trump no matter what he does
that could be 15 20 25 % I don't know
exactly what it is right now but the
point is Trump's bottom for approval is
not zero and his top for approval is not
100 even with George W Bush when things
were less partisan after 9/11 Bush saw a
massive spike in approval to 90 or 88
percent something like that that was
probably his ceiling and those were the
absolutely most extenuating
circumstances so the point is when
Trump's approval moves from 49 to 39 49
to 39 it's in that range it's really a
lot more than that because there the
bottom is not zero and the top is not
100 pick what numbers you think it is
with Trump it's probably something like
I don't think his approval no matter
what he does would go below 25 or maybe
even 28 something like that and I don't
think it would go higher than probably
80 no matter what he does so in the
context of a range that is more like 28
to 80 a 10-point swing is pretty
significant but there's a lot of people
in this country who will never abandon
him it might be for their own self
esteem they don't want to admit to
themselves that they made a mistake when
they voted Trump in 2016 and the way to
at least trick your brain into thinking
you didn't make a mistake is to vote for
him again in 2020 there's this quote
incorrectly attributed to Mark Twain
it's still a good quote just not Mark
Twain the quote is it's easier to fool
people than to convince them that
they've been fooled and along those
lines we have to understand why a lot of
2016 Trump voters are going to vote for
him again some may abandon him and
there's a very small margin there that
Trump can afford to lose before it
becomes almost impossible to win
reelection
but understand it's easier to fool
people than can then to convince them
they've been fooled and it is very
relevant in the times of front we'll
take a quick break and be back with much
more right after this make sure you're
following me on Instagram for the latest
urban garden and
updates at David Pakman the david pakman
show at david pakman.com the David
Pakman show depends on the support of
our viewers and listeners and one way to
keep us going is through patreon where
you can pledge as little as $1 per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
we're living in a very unusual timeline
my friends stock car racing League
NASCAR has banned the Confederate flag
at all events and properties period
while the President of the United States
on the same day a rich guy raised in New
York City is loudly defending
confederate named military bases in the
united states says he will not change
the names of those bases and is being
called the Confederacy second president
by a Republican group so especially for
our viewers outside the US but also for
people in the United States just as a
sort of refresher the Confederate flag
was the flag of the Confederacy in the
American Civil War you had the Union
versus the Confederacy some called that
North versus South the Confederacy
fighting for slavery sometimes they say
they were fighting for states rights to
which I always like to say states rights
to continue having legal slavery whereas
the Union was fighting to abolish
slavery of course the Union won and
slavery was abolished and the effects of
slavery of course took much longer than
just that war to actually deal with but
there are parts of this country where
Confederate flags are sometimes also
called the rebel flag they are revered
or fetishized in some way even in the
sort of hill towns in western
Massachusetts where I went near where I
went to high school you would have
places just ten or fifteen miles out of
Northampton Massachusetts which was a
super liberal little city that you know
the guys thought it was cool to drive in
to the vocational school with a pickup
truck that bore a confederate flag on
the back and there are those who I
believe rightly see it as a symbol of
hatred and oppression and there are
others who say it is a symbol of history
and heritage but in any case it is
widely now in popular culture being
eliminated and I quite frankly I believe
that it should be I mean would we apply
you know look at the losers in other
conflicts losers that are for
fortunately losers because they wanted
horrible things like could we say that
displaying Nazi flags just because they
lost is just its history like there was
a German military and it's just wrecking
like okay guys it's an extreme example
but I find it to be in very very poor
taste now this gets us to NASCAR NASCAR
in the United States is not known for
being made up of the most progressive
people now I'm not saying NASCAR fans
are all racists but it's certainly a
sport that leans more conservative in
terms of its fan base and it's one of
the few places where Donald Trump can
actually get himself a crowd that cheers
instead of a crowd that boos and it is a
place where unfortunately Confederate
flags are certainly more common than in
other sports you don't tend to see
Confederate flags at NBA games you don't
tend to see Confederate flags at major
league soccer matches and as far as I
know they wouldn't even be allowed in to
be perfectly frank but you do see them
at NASCAR races until now NASCAR has now
banned the display of the Confederate
flag at all events and properties and
notably NASCAR also removed its rule
that says racing team members have to
stand for the national anthem and we've
seen a number of sports leagues now say
you know if you don't want to stand you
actually don't have to stand so every
indication here is NASCAR sees what's
happening nationally since the killing
of George Floyd Bubba Wallace one of
their racers has been very supportive a
drivers I think they're called has-been
shows what I know has been very
supportive of the protests and they are
making a decision that there is going to
be no more Confederate stuff at their
races now is it because everybody
involved
morally believes that there shouldn't be
Confederate flags I don't know
certainly they've made the business
decision that there will be no more
confederate flags they're not
everybody's happy NASCAR Truck Series
driver ray sitter le Ciccarelli wrote on
his Facebook page he's gonna quit after
this season because Confederate flags
have been banned have fun buddy don't
let the door hit you on the way out and
then here's the real amazing contrast
look at the last 24 hours in NASCAR
okay and compare that to the last 24
hours of Trump Trump putting out a
statement and tweeting that he will not
change the names of Confederacy themed
military bases saying quote it has been
suggested that we should rename as many
as 10 of our legendary military bases
such as Fort Bragg in North Carolina
Fort Hood in Texas Fort Benning in
Georgia these monumental and very
powerful bases have become part of a
great American heritage and a history of
winning victory and freedom the United
States of America trained and deployed
these our heroes on these hallowed
grounds and won two world wars therefore
my administration will not even consider
the renaming of these magnificent and
fabled military installations our
history as the greatest nation in the
world will not be tampered with respect
our military now what's funny about
respect our military is that remember
the Union won the Civil War meaning that
the military should be respected the
military that should be respected is the
military that fought against the
Confederacy because we won the Union won
so when you name the fort's after the
side of that lost that was killing the
precursor to our current military the
Confederacy that fought for slavery
doesn't really make a lot of sense
because you've named forts after people
who were against our military they did
not respect our military so listen this
is not the biggest issue I don't really
care what the fort's are called although
it doesn't make a lot of sense to me
that we named him after the losers who
wanted to keep slaves but who would have
guessed as Barack Obama was leaving
office that during the subsequent
presidential term NASCAR would take the
more progressive stance of banning the
Confederate flag compared to the
president who defends Confederacy era
statues figures heroes whatever they
like to call them Republican group the
Lincoln project which is a Republican
group that opposes Trump has now come
out and said Trump is the Confederacy's
second prize
this is a Republican group which put out
a statement where they said we never
imagined when we named our initiative to
defeat the re-election of Trump the
Lincoln project that the president would
go as far as honoring the Confederate
generals who fought against the United
States to preserve slavery and uphold
white supremacy for all intents and
purposes Trump today became the
Confederacy's second president we cannot
allow this and then they go on to say we
need help from Republicans to remove
Donald Trump in November strange times
but I believe the decision by NASCAR is
the correct one whatever their reasons
for doing it and it's probably a mix of
understanding the way society is going
combined with the fact that it's
probably a bad PR move to continue
having these flags displayed they did
ultimately come to the right decision a
Republican wonders whether colored
people his word colored people get
coronavirus more because they don't know
or refuse to wash their hands in other
words are dirty immigrants more likely
to get coronavirus and they happen to be
the colored ones this is the question
from a guy who should never show his
face in public again his name is Steve
Huffman he's a Republican state senator
in Ohio didn't really have to tell you
he was a Republican as some of you know
coronavirus is disproportionately
hitting the non-white population of the
United States there are different
reasons why some of our non-white
populations in the US have more
underlying health conditions that can be
linked to poverty often poverty brings
with it poor health pre-existing
conditions appear to D predispose people
to more serious cases of coronavirus you
then also have to account for sometimes
having in access to inferior medical
services there's a lot of different
factors here but the point is we know
that minorities including black
Americans are being disproportionately
hit by coronavirus during a hearing
about racism Ohio State Senator Steve
Hoffman asked is it possible that the
black and
colored population might be getting hit
harder by coronavirus because they don't
wash their hands as well as white people
essentially proposing the idea that
these folks are dirtier they're not
washing their hands as well or as
frequently now get ready for this
Huffman is a doctor he said quote my
point is I understand african-americans
have a higher incidence of chronic
conditions and it makes them more
susceptible to death from Kovich but why
it doesn't make them more susceptible to
just get kovat could it just be that
African Americans or the colored
population do not wash their hands as
well as other groups or wear a mask or
do not socially distance themselves that
could be the explanation of the higher
incidence now Ohio Commissioner on mine
or the Ohio Commission on minority
health director Angela Dawson said what
Huffman is asserting is not the opinion
of leading medical experts in this
country that probably doesn't come as a
surprise to you
so either the implication as black
people don't wash their hands correctly
because they don't know how or black
people don't wash their hands correctly
because they're dirty and they don't
care to wash their hands pick your
explanation as to what Steve Huffman is
saying here and then of course you know
this reference to the colored population
like what year are we in again and for
me this is more proof that we need more
people from younger generations who it
would never even occur to to use this
language in these positions of power and
it's also a reminder that just because
you're a doctor doesn't mean you're
necessarily smart look at some of the
things Ben Carson believes if you need
proof of that now one last thing let's
for a second take seriously the question
of are there hand-washing differences
among populations because this has been
studied we're linking to one such study
and the conclusions from this study were
that women tend to wash their hands more
and better in other words using soap and
scrubbing long enough women are better
hand washers than men
non-white people are better hand washers
than white people when this has been
studied disproportionately white men are
the worst offenders when it comes to
bathroom hand washing we're linking to
this study in the description to the
YouTube video for this story certainly
something to think about this guy should
never show his face in public again we
have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine two david p here's
something great a self-described boomer
called in to the show
this woman is delightful she has the
requisite david pakman show playing in
the background while she leaves the
voicemail this is just a classic now for
david pakman show callers we had a call
last week from someone who said why
aren't the boomers out protesting and i
pointed out you know it always tends to
be younger populations that
disproportionately protest and we have a
pandemic that disproportionately affects
older folks so it seems totally expected
and reasonable that we're not seeing as
many baby boomers out protesting check
out this voicemail from my new favorite
david pakman show caller hi I'm Huma I'm
68 years old and you know what there are
a lot of bloomers out there protesting
but those of us who have all respiratory
disease and who are extremely vulnerable
to the corona virus really hesitate
about putting ourselves into big groups
of people of course so anyway that's my
concern
makes absolute perfect sense
delightful self-described boomer with
the David Pakman show playing in the
background you were completely right and
this was exactly what I said I and it
just makes sense
and listen after what happened to Martin
Gugino 75 year old protester who got
knocked down by police hit the back of
his head bled from his ear and spent
nearly a week in the hospital if you're
going to assume that as an older person
the police won't manhandle you that is
not being born out we have at least a
half a dozen incidents including the
elderly man walking with a cane I forget
where maybe it was Atlanta although if
it wasn't I apologize who was knocked
down by police there's a bunch of these
incidents so I I don't believe for a
second that the so-called boomers
necessarily don't support what's going
on but they seem to understand the risks
associated with gathering in large
crowds we're seeing what's happening in
Texas Florida as they've reopened
spiking cases it's ugly so I totally
understand and respect what they're
doing here's something fun if things are
so negative lately come on and do
something fun Tuesday night
this is Tuesday June 16 8:00 p.m.
Eastern Time 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5 Pacific
David Pakman show chess tournament
number two I don't care if you have
never played chess I mean you want to
know how the pieces move but the point
is open to all skill levels join the
tournament we will be streaming it live
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern but you don't have
to just watch me play in the tournament
you can play in it you can register on
Leach s org so that you're ready to go
that's Li Ches dot organ it's gonna be
great we had 500 people roughly play
last time I'm hoping that we do far
better than that this time and of course
remember that we have a daily free
podcast that you can sign up for on
Spotify Apple iTunes Google Play etc etc
etc the daily audio podcast another
great way to receive the show on today's
bonus show we will be covering dr.
Anthony foul G's latest coronavirus
comments we will talk about US soccer
lifting the ban on kneeling during the
national anthem and amazon has banned
police use of its face recognition
technology for a year is this PRBS are
significant all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show become a
member at join pakman.com and we'll see
you on the bonus show or tomorrow
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinka the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try blinka store free and save 25%
off of a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash david pakman I've
also included the link right underneath
this video